Okay. So, um,
with stalling on our final novel,
and I'm very glad this is Faulkner.
Um,
there's some of these stories to tell
about Faulkner just about the competition
after normal. Um, so this started
out having a different title.
Um,
it started out being called dark house,
so you can see that it really is right
on the other side of the spectrum. Um,
and it's really interesting the thing
that actually this novel could be
described as either dark
house or late in August.
So really late and downfalls. The
other two constitutive parts, Bernardo,
even though it's the light that has
been highlighted in the present title,
um, in fact, it could just
as well had been dark. Uh,
this is what Faulkner says about,
um,
the title that we now have late in August.
Um,
this is much later. Um, he, um,
when he was hopping about it,
um,
the University of Virginia in
1957 in August in Mississippi,
there's a few days somewhere about the
middle of the month when actually just
fortes or fall is cool.
There's a [inaudible] and luminous
quality to the light as though it came not
from today,
but from back in the old classic times
in my Alphonse and Santos and the gods
from police.
And that's all that the title meant.
It was just to me lessened evocative
title because it reminded me of that time
of who luminosity older than
our Christians through ization.
Maybe the connection is
we've been a growth who has
something of that plague and
quality. This is great. Um,
Andrew Point two novel,
um,
is about the quality of
light in Mississippi.
So it has a very important
local dimension to it,
but in also is sees itself as completely,
um,
looking back to extremely long literary
tradition going back to the classic
times. Um, and in fact
it predates Christianity.
So that's very important, um, to consider
it as well is that Christianity is very,
very important in this novel.
Um,
but it's very important to remember
that thought and actually also has a
reference point that is older
than Christianity. So, um,
because thought that was talking about
funds and Seth has just, you know, I mean,
I think the dose was,
I just words to most of it.
So I just found some illustration
is this is from the Roman mosaics.
Um, the satire, so he can see
it. Basically, it's a huge, uh,
like human beings except
the WHO's the feet, uh, uh,
the WHO's of a goat.
So that's really the,
this is not a very pretty,
um, image on the farm.
I think that in our minds
with 10 to thing of the fine,
it's very delicate and graceful,
um,
but as they have kind of an
animalistic dimension to it. Um,
and this is more of probably looking
more like our stereotypical image of the
foreign, very graceful. Uh, but
nonetheless we're to WHO's of a goat.
So, um, and, uh,
as I lay down and we talked a lot about
the relation to train animals and humans,
um, so it's very important
to keep that in mind as well,
just in the reference to the fun.
Faulkner is,
uh, invoking that whole
uncertain boundary. Um,
and then in between is
between human and animal.
Um, and as the satire actually
has the even long history,
if the phone basically is
Roman, um, set high, has a,
it goes back to the fifth
century BC basically is Rick
and there's a whole genre
called satire comedy if
filtering this creature. Um,
it's again looking for the most
part, like a human being. Um,
but having the tail of a horse
and also the ears of a daunting,
um,
just to see the way in which the satire
has been reactivated and picking up and
reading incarnated in the 20th century.
Here is someone have the ears of I,
you know,
we them the Vulcans ears,
but looking at your faculty like the
ears of the satire a and here's another
image. Basically the ears are the
giveaway of this creature. Also small, um,
very, not very noble looking compared
to the human being onto the guard.
Um, so, but father, even though he's
interested in the center in Florence,
he's not really writing about them.
He, he's mostly interested in Lena, um,
and the fact that she is
a pagan character to him.
So more on Lena.
She was never ashamed of that child,
whether it had any father or not.
She was simply going to the conventional
laws of the time and find his father.
But as far as she was concerned,
she didn't especially need any father
Fred any more than the women that on whom
Jupiter,
bigger children when answers
for home and her father.
So father seems to be really interested
in women who get Brandon out of wedlock,
right with vendors. Um, and as
I laid down in Dewey doubt, um,
and um,
the,
the kind of way in which that is
the constant burden on her mind.
Um, and it seems that he now has gone
to the other side of the spectrum. Um,
if pregnancy was a
constant burden on Dewey,
Dell's mind here,
it appears that it is not a burden at all.
Um,
leaners mine and maybe
that's why she's a pagan, um,
is that it's completely okay to be proud
and our web long not to have a father
not as aware that father, um,
as the father of your child. Um,
and the reason that is the case is that
Jupiter has had this long history of
having father, many children, um,
who can point to with her as the father,
Jupiter, suse, um, as the father,
but otherwise not having a human father.
So it's a completely honorable thing to
have a baby when you don't know who the
father is.
And the most famous example of
course is someone called leader,
right?
So you guys know I'm picking
two very chase illustrations,
a leader and this one, this
one being suits, obviously. Um,
but you can, if you would just go and
look it up, you can find numerous,
other than the stations, I'm also a
chase, uh, showing Leda and the Swan,
and this is the most famous example,
um, Leidos married to someone else.
And so it was just was enamored of her.
So he comes to her in the form
of a swan and the offspring one,
the most famous offspring
from that union was Helen.
So basically the whole of the Iliad,
the whole of the artists,
they really comes from this
union between Beta and sooth.
Um,
and there would have been no attic at
all if that had not been this union
between leader and someone
who's not quite human. Um,
so here's another
illustration. This one is, uh,
Greg and this one is Roman was again
Roman most say in many modern incarnations
as well. Um, yeah, he's also
has a poem about leader.
So basically someone who
goes down in history as, um,
and kind of thought if even though
it's not presented in this way,
but she's really going down in history
as the most honorable instance of
pregnancy outside of wet bar. Um, so,
but farmers also not writing
leaders story either, right?
He's writing leaners story.
So this is very much a case of
Lena updating the American Lena,
updating the Greek data. Um, she,
even though maybe she doesn't
know the father or maybe you know,
but she's not sure that she can get
the legitimate wedded husband to be the
father of the top. She's definitely
going to go and, and you know,
she's going to get someone.
So it was her destiny to have a
husband and children and she knew it.
And so she went out and attended to it
completely matter with that, you know,
this is the American case is not the
old classic times and the more I in 20th
century America, you need
to find a guy. So, um,
she's on the road, um, to
find this guy, uh, who,
whom she still thinks is thought
to be out of the actual father.
So today's lecture is really
about the updating of, um,
of, of this, the old
classmate when mother,
and um,
this is the structure of today's lecture.
The way that I've been talking
about. Obviously, you know,
this is going to be comedy
on the part of Lena.
So it's comedy and
especially sex as comic. Um,
but because this is a road
novel, one of the Manny, um,
it also has an epic
dimension to it. Um, and,
and now the innovation that foreigner is
bring to bear on novel and that really
is a serious,
uh,
updating of the classic epic calamity,
um,
is the introduction of two.
Allegorical name's Byron and burden.
So,
um, but just, just let,
um, they want to go back,
still linger with the
classics for a moment. Um,
in the defining comedy
in that particular way.
Usually we just think of comedy is,
you know, like Jane Austin, you know,
that would be comedy. Um, having,
having, uh, but actually, um,
in the poetics,
Aristotle defines a common thing in
slightly different way than Natalie is
closer to the way that I would like to
talk about comedy in this class in the,
he's has the participants in comedy,
we're car commodore die not from the bean
revelers but because they wander from
one village to another.
So wandering on the row people,
persons who are inferior,
not however going all the way to fool
villainy but imitating the ugly a wish
doesn't do the interest is one pot.
The ludicrous that is,
is a failing of or a piece of Berliners
which causes no pain or destruction with
a very content into the
definition of comedy.
A lot of it is, is not
that nice. You know,
it has to do with villainous people,
but not going all the way to food.
Villainy ugly people.
But again,
not going all the way.
So that other lady speak about it has
a lot to deal with people who are not
knowable. And that really is the
classic definition of comedy.
The emphasis really less on,
um,
the happy ending then on the
fact that they are low born, um,
that they are low in every other way,
that they don't rise to the,
to the tragic height of nobility,
which is the elevation proper to um,
to,
to tragedy. Um, combinate
is of much lower elevation.
Um, so they are sometimes
the Chris, um, they uh,
basically not at we will people,
um,
but as one result of not being completely
admirable is that they actually
survive quite well. They
actually manage to, um,
you know, to hang in there. Um,
so they bring no pain or destruction
either to themselves or to other people.
Once again, this is the
exact opposite, a tragedy.
We have mass destruction
at the end of tragedy.
Everything about the challenge that
you're Troy of all the tragedies based on
the story to try and master
introduction here. Um, accommodate.
It's just that everyone is going
to be able to survive. So, um,
with that definition in mind,
um,
less thing about the ways in
which Lena as peg and there,
especially in relation to her sexuality
and the way the five that represents
this aspect of him, the
human condition. Um,
and this is the story of
how Lena gets pregnant.
She's lab in the lean to room
at the back of the house.
It had a window which she learn to open
and close again in the dark without
making noise to live the eight years
before she opened the window for the first
time,
she had not opened it a
dozen times Hartley before
she discover that should not
have opened it at Oh, she said
to herself, that's just my luck.
Two weeks later she climbed
again through the window.
It was a little difficult this time
even had been this hard to do before.
I reckon that would not be doing it. Now
she talked. So the UN has, or I know this,
what could have been seen as tragic,
traumatic,
the kind of devastation of one person's
life, one poses line being ruined,
all that is told through binos
relation to the window, um,
that she can open it without making a
noise that's just done it a few times and
then she realized this shouldn't have
done it. And then the final time,
it's really hard, but she wished that
it had been that hard to begin with.
So it's all told through this completely
off focus of center relation to the
main event and is,
it doesn't,
it doesn't seem especially bad really,
you know,
even though this matter of inconvenience
and that really is what the pregnancy
is to lean that it is a matter
of inconvenience isn't nuisance.
That is not so easy for her to
get out the window this time. Um,
and just to remind us the
farm that doesn't always
write about sexuality in this
way.
And let's just go back to a character who
was completely non pagan and this none
other, um, more normal striking example.
Quentin, um, in the sound of the fury. Um,
so this is what you think
thinks about women's sexuality,
delicate equilibrium or periodic
filth between two moons,
balance moons. He says full and
yellow as harvest moons, her hips,
thighs,
liquid faction like drunk
things floating like power,
rubber laterally filled, getting the
border of honeysuckle. Oh, mixed up.
So for Quentin and indeed
for most non big and,
uh, characters, there's a good part
of the world that is repugnant,
that is just really repulsive.
Um,
and it turns out that women and
sexuality is part of that very,
very prominent,
uh,
well and so it's not great
to live in a world like that.
That's really why Quentin
does what he does. Um,
for someone like Lena for his
Pagan, um, much of the world,
in fact, probably all of the
world is not Republican, you know,
is inconvenience. Sometimes
it's a little ugly flow, messy,
but it's not rebelling. And that's
why she is where she is. Um,
so on,
so this is one way we can think about
Lena in version tell you that she's not
the only character. So there's
novel is actually not that comic,
but her share of the novel
as comic and in that way.
But um,
even though there is now
this defines comedy as um,
as basically the journey, um, that
is undertaken by ignoble persons.
The more recognizable modern
obviously is the epic journey, right?
So anytime we think of someone travelling
on the road, we thing of the APIC Jara.
Um,
and that is very much in play.
We're that employed elsewhere in Faulkner
is her imagine the way here as well.
And this is actually a kind
of not so funny a killer.
It's interesting to see what
the tone of this is. Um,
of description of Lena being underwrote,
building muse plot in a steady
and unflagging hypnosis.
The vehicle does not seem to progress
like a shabby beat upon the mile red
string of rope. So much so is this
that in the watching of it, the,
I loses a site and sense drowse Linwood
and land the road itself with all the
peaceful and monotonous changes
between darkness and day,
like already measure thread
being rewind onto a school.
So that Alaska as though our sound
trivial and unimportant Asian beyond even
distance,
the sound of it seems to come slow and
terrific and without meaning as though it
were,
goes traveling a half mile ahead
of his own shape rate description.
Um, and it's, um,
it's on a different register can see
that it's really on a different tone.
No register from Lina having
trouble climbing out the window. Um,
and I would say that that the,
there's a complicated relation between
the APIC drama and the comic genre in
this novel on the whole,
uh,
what the addict genre
brings to this novel, um,
is the sense of some of a
journey that simply has to go on,
um, is not even especially,
um, pleasurable,
um, is just stretches on, um, yesterday.
Just the thing more in terms of
paradigm that we've been using, um,
tomorrow is going to be exactly like
today and going to be exactly like
yesterday is the state
repetition of the same. Um,
that defines this kind of epic journey.
So it is peaceful and monotonous and
image that thoughtfully uses is that it's
like already measured the threat
being rewarmed onto the spoon,
right? There's absolutely
nothing new under the sun.
It is just an old story being
told over and over again.
Um, and um, the complete, um,
exclusion of anything that is dramatic
from this sense of the journey.
So it's in many ways it's very hard to
write a novel based on the fact that it's
completely monotonous and as part
of the challenge of, you know,
I promise you the rest of where as
with anything but monotonous, but um,
leaders part of it,
Ashley aspires to be monotonous in a
good sense in the sense that there's
really, um, is good. You know, that
there's no dramatic development,
there's no catastrophe.
That's really what Faulkner has.
The back of his head is that could,
has to fade is what defines tragedy.
Non Catastrophe is more
defiance comedy. So, um,
just to give you a sense of the
way in which this epic journey,
it's been incarnated and
incarnated American literature,
two other very famous novelists,
Jack Heroin on the road.
And more recently, this apocalyptic
instance of that calming in the car,
the, the road, um,
foreigners on the road, um,
is a low different from those two.
Um,
so today we'll think about all the
ingredients that go into his making of his
road novel has to deal with
kindness of strangers, um,
has to do with something
like switch ability. Um,
if the journey is going to be
pretty monotonous for Lina,
the scar to be some variation, right?
It has to alternate with something else.
So it turns out that actually,
even though the protagonist who itself
is two is peaceful for the story to be
very dramatic. Um, there
will be other people,
the supporting counts actually
with supply, the drama.
So there's a kind of as a switch
and below they be him, um,
where the action or where the
drama is going to come from.
As long as Lena is concerned,
the drama is going to come from the
supporting cast rather than from Vienna
herself.
Um,
and this for which ability in terms of
the relation to train the weighty and
that Monday.
And then I'll talk about jurrens as well.
So there's the outline of what is to come,
but let's just stay with the kindness
of strangers, uh, for a little bit. Um,
leaners come by farm.
Um, and the reason, um,
that the journey is so
peaceful and monotonous is
that there's an endless supply
of people who would do things for right,
who will be the suppliers of hospitality,
um,
to keep going.
And that too is very Greek.
We know that hospitality is
one of the key virtues, um,
in Greek cocksure that when a stranger
comes to supposed to feed them,
shelter them, give them
presence when they go away. Um,
that is the understanding of the basic
model that are exchanged between human
beings is that you're good to people,
you think the first time and
that you never see again. Um,
so this Google hardly the something of
that and the way that and at has being
treated,
the evocation of far is the peaceful
corridor paved with unflagging and
triumphal faith and people
with kindness and thing.
Those faces and voices,
Lucas version, I don't know.
I don't know anybody by that name around
here. This road. It goes to Honda.
He might be there as possible. Here's a
work in this going a piece of the way,
we'll take you that far.
So these people are completely
faceless and nameless.
They really aren't complete strangers.
They're not meant to be remembered
or to be encountered again,
even though,
and sometimes actually picks up some
of them and there's other novels,
but they're meant to recede into the
background as part of that peaceful and
monotonous corridor and which it is
completely safe for being a travel right.
So it's,
this has of guarantees safety due to
the guarantee hospitality of strangers.
But we know that it's,
the kindness of strangers has got to take
a dramatic turn for there to be a good
story into the novel. So we're
actually seeing a very soon, um,
and it comes about,
um,
through leaners interaction with a couple,
she was being taken in by this couple,
um,
and it turns out that they arrive or of
Lena careism and leisure upheaval in the
life of this married couple.
So all of a sudden Lina recedes
into the background. So, you know,
we can also to switch ability.
We can also add the switch ability
between foreground and background.
Lina recedes into the background as the
supporting cast comes to the foreground.
So this is the exchange between the arms.
There's,
he cannot tell from her voice
if she's watching him or not.
Now he to Howard's himself
with his lead flowers,
said maybe she will ever is running away
from her is after I reckon is going to
find out can made a bad mistake when he
started before he put the Mississippi
River and train them.
And now he knows that she's
watching him do gray woman,
not plum enough then men hot work
on in a serviceable Greg Garman,
one savage and bras her hands on her hips,
her phase like those of generals who
had been defeated in battles you man.
She says,
what do you want to do about it?
To other out whether it's
sleeping the by maybe you men,
she says done there.
So this is all we are going to early.
We'll get one more a little bit for this,
but this is really, um, for
as far as staff nurse one.
So this is completely adequate fleas
standing snapshot of the marriage.
Um,
and I would say that it is as interesting
as the marriage between Cora and her
husband and how, um,
except that is sort of,
is at the moment of
tension between the two.
So we know that what kinds
of people, these are the
poor whites. One more, right?
People where,
who can afford and how and use
split flowers after a towel.
Um,
and the re the way that they
actually know each other very well.
So, um, arms to, doesn't
have to look as the arms.
Um, Armstead doesn't have to look. Um,
usually to see issues
watching him on that,
it really says a lot about
what kind of relationship, um,
it is that you can just tell by the
tone of voice whether or not the other
person's looking at you.
So that for me is a measure of
how good our marriage is that,
you know, you know, your companion,
that why, just a tone of words,
we'll be able to tell you exactly the
posture, the physical departure, um,
of this person. Um, so initially you
can really tell. Um, but then, um,
once he says something, once
he said, okay, you know,
that this guy is not going to be
able to escape from [inaudible].
Once he said that, then she know
instantly that she's looking at him.
Um, and we know what she
looks like. Um, serve, uh,
uh, uh, um,
most doing version I think of addy,
um,
but pretty much very much belonging
to the same socio economic group,
um, in a gray gum and, um,
working hard all alive,
but also not just work hard and all
this interesting and adjectives by a
[inaudible] man hot. I don't exactly
know what that means, man. Hot.
It's just that maybe she is completely
resistant to the charms of men.
Maybe that's one definition of
what it means to be man hall. Um,
certainly she's worked hard all her
life and maybe the two adjectives are
related in that way. There's a way in
which, you know, if you will so hodge, um,
all your life, you're kind of immune to
a chance of other people, men and women.
Um, so she is immune to the
charms. Her husband, um,
and her face is like the phase of
generals who've been defeated in,
um, it is, we reference,
um, it is not, you know,
the civil war is really not important.
Um, in this who are the, no,
actually it was very,
very important to another character,
but it's not going to Reno.
Um,
the civil was front and
center for another character,
but it's oddly intrudes into this moment
when it really is not the reference
point.
Um,
but they are at high history of the
south is in the acts in this reference of
Mrs arms, this face looking
like, um, the face of general.
So she is in many ways
she's more like a man, um,
than like a woman. Um, I
know there's actually, um,
that when I came to this sections,
uh,
last week and I enjoyed them very much.
Some of you mentioned that they cause
is financially, uh, more like a man.
So it's rosemary.
Rosemary is financially more like a man.
So the Fitzgerald has also thought about
the ways in which they could be across
gender dynamics in people,
otherwise completely feminine. Um,
and here's,
she doesn't look especially
feminine and across Gender Dynamics,
um, much, much more powerful here.
So she is like the general
who's been defeated in battle.
Maybe she's been defeated in life just
because there's been such a hard life,
although you know that. So,
um, or just that you know,
that it didn't go exactly
the way she wanted. Uh,
we don't know the contents
of that phrase that you know,
that we'll have phases like the face
of generals who had been defeated. Um,
we also don't know,
but that's the least of it.
We don't know why she suddenly saying
what she's saying to her husband.
And,
um,
honestly there's really not contemplating
having an affair with being right.
So the doorman is not really a
complaint against her husband.
It is a grievance that is probably
to record against the entire,
you know, half of the
human population, men, um,
that this is what men would do to women.
Um,
and her husband being an instance of that.
Although you know,
obviously there are many other episodes
in the marriage who might that might be
at the back of her mind. But in any
case, this completely out of the blue,
out of context,
outburst from Mrs arms that suggest that
this is both buffering good marriage
but also a complicated marriage as
all marriages would have to beat,
right if there's lasted for a long time.
So these two people know
each other very well. Um,
and he seems to know he knows better than
we do exactly what is going on in her
mind when she says you do
it, man. Um, and then this,
um, uh, further development
to this. And so, um,
she's actually now this, we're getting
into dramatic action for Mr. Thompson.
Whether are you fixing to do with your
egg money this time of night? He says,
I reckon his mind to do with what I like,
she just dumps into the land per phase,
hush better.
God knows it was me sweat over them
and nurse them. You never lifted.
No hand show is says,
I recommend a in any human in this
country is going to dispute them hands.
Will you lesson is the possums. And this
next, that rooster band leader, he says,
because two things suddenly to job's off
one shoe and strikes the China event,
the single Shannon glow from the bat
reclining Armstead watches her Gavin's
remaining coins from amount of China
Franklin's and drop them where the others
into the slack and nodded and really
nodded three or four times with savage
finality.
Um,
that is says satisfying representations
of arms giving or people we being
charitable and looking completely not
charitable when they're doing it. Right.
So this is the only way this woman would
allow herself to be a chair of the boat
is by looking as harsh
and bitter as she could.
Um, so, uh, uh,
before that [inaudible] had thought, well,
you know, maybe she's just into comfort,
jealous moon.
It was just going to not allow
leaner to stay in the house,
but it turns out that is
quite the opposite. Um,
and it's poly is a kind
of very calm, calm, calm,
calm class combination of recognizing
that yes, this is a young woman,
very attractive, um, that she's not
that young woman, very attractive. Um,
but recognizing maybe in some sense,
um,
that, you know, she also,
that this woman is embodying a long nurse
grievance that she has against man in
general, whatever the psychology, um,
she is in solidarity,
um,
with Lina without ever wanting
to be trade that solidarity,
right? So it is that complicated
kind of behavior, um,
that you want to do something for that
person that you never want to give
yourself away is doing
something. Um, so it,
it really is the,
uh,
the most interesting and dramatic
and psychologically and behaviorally
complicated kind of client
is or strangers, um,
is that is not definitely not the
traditional kind of arms giving.
So in terms of the narrative dynamics,
we can say that the arms does have
completely taken over the narrative,
right?
There's a complete switch between
Lena to suppose for tagging is,
um, and the two of them
be in the supporting cast.
It turns out that the supporting cast
that fall in probably spends more time
thinking about the supporting cast than
he does thinking about protagonists.
And that is a really interesting way to
define the protagonists is that maybe
the protagonist is someone you can
actually afford not to spend a of time
thinking about.
And that is really the supporting cast
that you have to give your energy to it.
A very interesting
definition of reversibility,
of the distribution of space, distribution
of attention within the story.
Um, and we've seen many instances of
this. So, um, just to, because we've,
we've just done with Gero just going to
remind you of a very obvious instance of
switch ability and tender is the night,
um,
in the description of Nicole that who
ran back is hanging from the pools,
right? So it, the human body is
hanging from the appendage, um,
uh,
completely switch the reboost degree
of importance between the person who
supposed to the protagonist and that
what is supposed to be just in the panel.
And of course that such ability that is
played out not only in terms of that one
particular detail but also in terms of
the entire narrative of is the night.
It turns out that Duke divers completely
upstage by Nicole as she becomes really
the main actor in the novel
that is becomes her story,
that she gets to dictate the outcome of
that story and he becomes her bandage
and dispensable appendage at
the end of the novel. So, um,
we've, we've seen this in Faulkner. Um,
basically on a very large macro scale in
terms of the entire narrative structure
of tender is the night in
thoughtless is much more local.
It's just this one moment,
um,
that this is switch relation to train
protagonists and supporting cast. Um,
but I also,
and but they're also plays
out in different registers
in tenders and light in
August.
So we'll look at one other also
local instance of such ability.
Um,
and this is the food non if the arms
that's represent the kinds of dramatic arm
of the novel where followed, can give
us high human psychological drama.
Um, w when it comes to Lena,
he, when he gives us is,
um,
kind of very small upheavals on
one is basic way of level platform,
but even on that very level of iPhone,
um,
their mile upheavals and it has to do
with the switch ability between the lady
and the mundane.
So she seems to museum
on the mountain road.
Why the slow spitting and squatting and
watch her coach Lee believing that she
is thinking about the man and the
approaching crisis when in reality she is
waging of mile battle with a prudential
caution of the earth of and with and by
which she lives.
This time she conquers,
she rises and walking Alo
awkwardly though carefully,
she traverses to rank battery of
man eyes and to see the store,
the Clo following,
I'm going to do it.
She thinks even ordering the cheese and
crackers and go into it saying allow and
a box of sardines she
caught themselves means.
So this is the essence of the drama
and the to be or not to be over in this
case, to do, not to do the,
to do or not to do, uh,
in Lenas consciousness revolves
around Abbas of Saturdays.
And that is completely okay for Faulkner
qualifies were to be the protagonists
of his novel.
So we really have to give some thought
to what it is that entitles a person to
be the protagonist of the novel.
We know that in Greek tragedy,
a person that has to be noble and it's
to have a very drastic downfall in all of
the power of art to be the
hero of the tragedy. Um,
and the modern comic novel,
nothing like that, just very,
very minor upheaval is okay. So, um,
[inaudible] I think that is because of
that very level platform because of that
basic,
very reliable continuum that is uh,
backed up, supported, uh,
by the kindness of strangers is
because of that continuum that we can,
a really interesting thing
with the practice and kind
of a stylistic take almost.
Um, in this particular
novel there was maybe some,
we've seen a little bit of
that and the other novels,
but this novel is really pronounced,
um,
has to do with the use of germs,
especially turning verbs into nouns.
We've seen a little bit of
that earlier in the passage,
but here it becomes this
in the fall foreground. Um,
that far within my
hearing before my seeing,
I will be writing within the hearing of
Lucas Bush before he seeing who would
hear wagon but he won't know.
So there will be one within his hearing
before he's seeing and then he was
seeing me and he will be excited.
And so there will be two within this
thing before he is normally highly
stylized. Um, basically there's
no way we can not know this.
The fact that the verbs, I mean
users now in this instance. Um,
so the way that we can maybe try
to make sense of it, it's very,
um,
self conscious practice on thoughtless
apart is by noticing how different an
image of Lucas Bush
we're getting from Lena.
How different from the image that we've
been getting just a moment ago? Uh, no,
actually just a moment later, um, from,
from Armstead answered knows exactly
what Lucas is doing is running away from
her.
Um,
it's just really unlucky that he hasn't
put the Mississippi River road between
himself and his woman.
Um,
so onset is a completely
accurate that noses and portrait.
What kind of a man Lukas brewers is.
Lina has a completely unrealistic out
of touch with reality or trade of Lucas.
She thinks that he'll be very glad to
see her and the he'll be excited and in
fact, it's not just one person
who's coming but tube. Um,
and so in many ways what Faulkner is
giving us in this very stylized linguistic
practice is to create a kind of
link it linguistic cocoon around,
uh,
Lena that cheers insulated by this an
idiomatic use of English just as she was
insulated by an interpretation of reality
that really has very little to do with
the reality would be truth
about Lucas Bert. Um,
it is very much a kind of linguistic
shelter in which she can afford to keep on
thinking in this way about the man
who keeps running away from her.
Um,
and this is why she can afford.
And why can't she be continued to
be completely unworried on anxious,
um, about her pregnancy that
that is just not, this is why,
how she can have war, she can prevent
that from becoming a burden on her.
Um, so we can think of this
as one element, you know,
color,
um,
as various authors do intervene to
make certain things possible for one
character that will not be
possible for other characters.
And this particular intervention they
use of is one stylistic device to make
sure that Lena is preserved in
a state of constant wellbeing.
So, um, there and,
but he's also clearly enough to know
that she really is completely dead wrong
about Lucas boat. So, um, this is, sorry,
fast forwarding to have much later moment.
Um,
but this is just to um,
bring Faulkner into a discussion
that we've been having
all through the semester,
which is about types, right? Weather,
um, certain people, characters,
um, can be classified, they'd
be allowed to broader groups,
they are groups that have labels.
Um,
so it turns out that he's also a
quite conscious of the fact that uh,
Lucas Bird Ashley is now
so much and individual, um,
as a type a type of man. Um, and he,
this is his commentary. Uh, oh,
this was actually hide how has gotten
a drink but is as good as farmers. Um,
commentary on the fate of Lena
growth for the Lena grows.
There are always two men in the
world and the number is lesion.
Lucas, Burgess and
Byron bunches, you know,
all of them has suddenly
appearing and thorough.
So the other roof herself is a type,
they,
the Lena rose off the world and then
they Lucas Burgess and burn bunches.
And this is really once say's Lena is
that she actually is one of the Lena rose
and her faith, um, is to
be unlucky in one sense.
And that she's stuck with
a male like Lukas boroughs.
But she's lucky in the sense
that you can just know,
I mean it's almost a kind of statistical
point that to every Lucas bird there
will be a Byron bunch, will
take care of her. So you know,
she was saving this way that there always
be the parent of two kinds of men in
her life. Um, so here is, you know,
the allegory thick and fast, um, Beverly,
very heavy handed and meant to
be noted as Byron Lebaron do,
you know, romantic poet. Um,
and with the added little joke,
I think he actually died and missile
lonely Italy has some reference to,
has some affinity to Mississippi as well.
And she would not be on and to thing
that there's a nice connection. Um, so,
um, it, um, the, so, so
here's Byron, you know,
being the namesake for apparently button,
um,
and sure enough he lives up
to his namesake, the, the,
the romanticism of his namesake.
Um, then baron fell in love.
He fell in love country to honor
tradition off his osteon jealous country
raising, which demands in the
object physical inviolability.
It happens on a Saturday afternoon while
he was alone at the no two miles away,
the house was still burning.
Two yellows smoke standing straight
as a monument on the horizon.
They side before noon when the smoke
first rose about the trees before the
whistle blew.
And the oldest department,
I reckon Barron could do today,
they said with a free five to watch,
um, the switch ability
is in high gear in here.
It starts out with Barron falling in love,
but that
romantic side of the story doesn't even
get to control the entire paragraph.
Um, basically it just
gets two sentences. Um,
and then the rest of the paragraph
is taken over by something like that.
It says nothing to do with romantic love.
And all of a sudden we realized that yes,
Byron is falling in love
at the same time as a very,
you know, that's dramatic
enough of this life. Um,
but this drama parent's life
is taking pot with a drama.
There's going to overtake the entire time,
which is the burning of a house.
Um,
and it's,
there's something and we also getting
another glimpse of what kind of people are
living in this town.
Um,
in the reference to
the free fire to watch.
This is not the strangers who are kind
to other strangers is a very different
poetry of the local community. So, um,
it turns out that Byron is not the only
person who has another core and call
names, but, and now you character, he does
as well. It's a big fire and other side.
What can they be?
I don't remember anything coming up that
way big enough to make all that smoke
except the burden house. Maybe that's
what it is. And then they said,
my pappy says he can remember how 50 years
ago folks said it ought to be burned.
And with a little human
fat man to start good.
Maybe you'll happens to the dock
there instead of fire with those,
then they laugh.
So this is the other are going to name
is that buyer is always going to be here
with someone whose name
is burden and burden.
Why is not,
as you know,
there's no Byron I'm two clues and uh,
there's actually a very famous poem that
was sudden suggest to us the origins of
that name Kipling's poem,
White Man's burden and take out the
white man's burden and leap is Ole reward
the blame of those eat better.
The hate of leave of those you got,
I think we've a completely misguided
wrong headed notion as Waco.
Kipling's white man's burden is not really
about how great it is to take up the
white man's burden,
but how awful it is and that you
incur the hatred of lost of people.
Um, so this is what, um, the,
what the elk oracle names of how they
function in light in August and how
farmers really updating the old classic
story is that it really is the story
about the fate of someone call Byron
and the fate of someone call burden.
And obviously there are
other characters who, uh,
invoke through those two characters,
but they're both on fire.
Baron is on fire because
it's falling in love.
Join the [inaudible] naturally is on
fire and as she's being burned alive,
oh no, she's dead. But
at that point, but, um,
she's on fire by itself. So, um, she's,
that is also a contribution
to the lighting and all this.
And that's why the
other alternative title,
dark house is business improved really.